[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing some events
and characters from the Harry Potter
books that would subsequently omitted
from the films the fact that some of
these events characters were never shown
on screen has certainly always been a
sore subject for Harry Potter book fans
but today I've got some good news just
recently a new Harry Potter TV show was
announced for HBO and I suspect that
this could be what we've all been
waiting for a chance to finally view
some of these unexplored moments places
and characters on screen the show is
allegedly set to span a decade and
provided that the actors have to age to
play their older selves I'd be willing
to bet that this decade-long promise is
going to be somewhat accurate with that
said a decade-long TV series exploring
the books presents an awful lot of
opportunity to uncover and unravel
aspects of the story that may have never
been brought to the Silver Screen and
I'm here for it without further ado his
10 pieces of Uncharted film territory
Dumbledore's funeral in the books
Dumbledore's funeral is a somber an
emotional affair that brings together
many of the main characters in the
series the funeral was attended by
witches and wizards from all around the
Wizarding World who came to pay their
respects to the greatest Headmaster
Hogwarts ever had classes and exams were
put off for the funeral and the chorus
of Mer people sang a tribute from below
the lake surface it was a moment of
closure for the characters and us the
readers as we said goodbye to one of the
most important figures in the series
omitting Dumbledore's funeral from the
film version of Harry Potter and the
Half Blood Prince was a controversial
decision as many fans felt it was a
crucial scene that should have been
included however it turns out that the
reason for its Omission was related to
the film's budget being deemed just too
expensive to film this is surprising
given the commercial success of the
books and films but what can you do the
Marauders James Potter Sirius Black
Remus Lupine and Peter Pettigrew come
price the Marauders a group of four
Gryffindor boys that got up to all sorts
of Mischief while attending Hogwarts
School together the four boys created
the Marauders map a tool with which they
were able to navigate the school and
avoid the prying eyes of professors the
Marauders were important because they
were integral to the backstory of the
series particularly in terms of Harry's
connection to his father and the rise of
Lord Voldemort the Marauders also had a
huge role in the backstory of Severus
Snape whom they bullied relentlessly at
school the story of the Marauders was
ultimately left out of the Harry Potter
films because it was not considered
essential to the main plot of the series
however this decision was met by fans
with a considerable amount of scrutiny
gaunt family history Tom Riddle's
Origins the pensive is a magical object
that allows users to view memories as if
they were watching a movie in the Harry
Potter series Dumbledore uses the
pensive to show Harry memories of the
Court Family on a couple of different
occasions the gaunt family is an
important part of Voldemort's backstory
as they are his maternal relative
Voldemort's grandfather marvolo gaunt
was a powerful wizard who possessed the
resurrection Stone one of the Deathly
Hallows nestled inside of the infamous
gaunt Family ring the same ring that in
a roundabout way LED to Dumbledore's
death
Voldemort's mother Mary gaunt was a
tragic figure who fell in love with a
muggle Tom Riddle senior and was
abandoned by him when she became
pregnant with Voldemort the gaunt family
history is important because it sheds
light on Voldemort's Twisted Origins and
his obsession with pure blood Wizardry
these memories offer important insights
into Voldemort's past and motivations
particularly his obsession with
immortality and his disdain for his
muggle Heritage I would love it moving
forward it put a lot of focus into this
as Voldemort's origin story is something
that I've always wanted to see on screen
apparently the decision to cut these
memories came from the filmmaker's
desire to streamline the story and focus
on Harry's Journey nevertheless these
would have been a great addition to the
films Hermione's how self-activism spew
spew AKA The Society for the promotion
of elfish welfare is an aspect of the
books that didn't appear in the films at
all in the books a mighty embarks on a
crusade to ensure that house elves who
are heavily mistreated are saved in turn
she creates the society for the
promotion of elfish welfare as a way to
raise awareness about the mistreatment
of househelves and to improve their
working conditions Hermione starts a
society after she sees winky an elf who
isn't in the films being treated
horribly Hermione's advocacy for the
rights of ourselves is an important
subplot in the Harry Potter series as it
shows her compassion and commitment to
social justice even in the face of
opposition from other witches and
wizards spew was cut from the films
because it was considered a side plot
but little relevance to the main
storylines of the books however this
decision did stunt Hermione's character
development to a degree this Omission
segues nicely into the next one winky
the house elf winky was a house self in
the Harry Potter series that was
introduced in the fourth book Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire she was a
devoted servant of the Crouch family
particularly Barty Crouch senior and was
dismissed from the family's service
after being found with a wand under
suspicious circumstances after being
sacked winky goes into a deep depression
and comes to alcoholism finding solace
in butterbeer when key story is
important because it highlights the
mistreatment of house Elves and the
complicated power dynamics that exist
between Wizards and their servants
Sphinx's riddle in Goblet of Fire in the
Goblet of Fire Harry Potter encounters
the Sphinx during the third task of the
Triumph was a tournament it had the body
of an over large line great clawed Paws
and a long yellowish tale ending in a
brown tuft its head however was that of
a woman she turned her long
almond-shaped eyes upon Harry as he
approached the Sphinx's riddle is a key
moment in Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire that test the wit and intelligence
of the try was a tournament contestants
The Riddle is as follows first think of
the person who lives in Disguise who
deals in secrets and tells naught but
lies next tell me what's always the last
thing to mend the middle of middle and
end of the end and finally give me the
sound often heard during the search for
a hard to find word now string them
together and answer me this which
creature would you be unwilling to kiss
it has been reported that the Sphinx's
riddles omitted from the film due to
time constraints
peeves the Poltergeist peeves is a
mischievous and chaotic presence in the
Hogwarts Castle the Delights in causing
trouble and annoying the students and
staff if you aren't already privy to
peeves here's Hogwarts Infamous
Poltergeist not to be confused with
ghosts poltergeists are essentially
indestructible spirits of chaos the name
Poltergeist is German in origin and
roughly translates as noisy ghost
although it is not strictly speaking a
ghost at all the Poltergeist is an
invisible entity that moves objects
slams doors and creates other audible
kinetic disturbances it has been
expressed that peeves has existed at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry since its Inception in 990 A.D
he purportedly came with the building
and though he's not a major character in
the books he certainly does add a sense
of whimsical humor to the story that is
missing from the films but the reason
for peeves not showing up in the films
is not a good one you see the role of
peeves was actually filled by actor Rick
male he even filmed his scenes however
when the film came out Mel's scenes were
mysteriously cut without any kind of
explanation
Neville's parents in their tragic story
never Longbottom's parents Frank and
Alice Longbottom were auras who were
tortured into Insanity by Bellatrix
Lestrange and other Death Eaters
Neville's relationship with his parents
is a key part of his character
development as he struggles with the
trauma of their condition and the
pressure of living up to their legacy
the reason for Neville's parents being
omitted from the Harry Potter films is
still not clear however there are a few
possible reasons the verse being that
their storyline may have just been too
dark the second possible reason is that
filmmakers may have instead wanted to
shift their focus to Neville's character
development highlighting his growing
confidence and bravery rather than his
dark history
Dumbledore's past Dumbledore's backstory
is a complex and fascinating part of the
Harry Potter series in the books we
learned that he had a troubled
relationship with his family
particularly his brother aberforth we
also learned about his relationship with
the dark wizard Gaelic Grindelwald which
ultimately led to tragedy and regret
Dumbledore's past is important because
it sheds light on its motivations and
his relationship with Harry I imagine
that Dumbledore's past was omitted so
that it wouldn't overshadow Harry or
change the direction of the films too
much it's also worth mentioning that
Dumbledore's past has been and hopefully
will be highlighted more in the
Fantastic Beasts films Voldemort's
application in the Half Blood Prince
there is a moment where Dumbledore using
the pensive shows Harry a memory of Tom
Riddle Voldemort applying for the
position of defense against a dark arts
teacher at Hogwarts this was the second
time that Voldemort had applied for the
position first being denied by the
previous Headmaster at the age of 18.
after being denied a second time
Voldemort Jinx is the role Paving the
way for all sorts of mayhem anyone who
may occupy the role in the future I
would have really appreciated this
staying in the films as it would have
shed some more light on why the turnover
for the data position was so high and
that's it for this video while the films
may have done an excellent job I still
think the best way to experience the
full richness and depth of JK Rowling's
world is via the books what else would
you like to see Incorporated in the new
show what other parts of the books would
you like to see immortalized leave a
comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live